and welcome back everybody we have a
brand new trial for you this week out of
Laredo Texas a border patrol officer
there faces the death penalty for
charges connected to the deaths of his
alleged mistress and their 20 month old
son Ronald Virgo sevillas had a child
with 28 year old Griselda Hernandez now
at the time he was living with another
woman who he also shared children with
in March of 2018 Hernandez reportedly
served the defendant child support
documents at his workplace a month later
investigators say that Hernandez asked
the defendant to meet her at a local
park after he said he wanted to see
their almost two-year-old son
prosecutors believe that the defendant
stabbed Hernandez and the little boy to
death on that visit Burgos Aviles is
pleading not guilty to capital murder
charges on Monday attorneys gave their
opening statements to the jury
prosecutors presented their theory of
motive in the case and the defense team
described the case as an anomaly for
their client
did what the right that every young
woman has who becomes pregnant when
there's a father who does not want to
make himself responsible she exercised
her right to go to the
Texas Attorney General and begin the
process
you will see the evidence of her trying
to say hey help me out
help me out March the 21st that was
already said you're going to see
evidence that that train was moving
that legal proceeding had already
started
and then something happens that had
never happened before
something happens
he says I want to meet
I want to meet Dominic he tells
chriselda
in a few weeks I don't think you're
going to want to be my friend
real subtle the evidence will show that
the meeting that he's setting up for
them
is not at the park
but it is in a dense Brushy area near
the Rio Grande river and Ronald Anthony
bultos fabulous
is lying
in weight
he is hiding
waiting for her to get close enough to
the truck
to carry out
his ambush in April 9 2018
Ronald to ask no prior criminal history
whatsoever
was accused of the murders of Griselda
and Dominique Hernandez
this is an enormous anomaly
an admiration
in Ronald's otherwise normal law-abiding
life he will die in person
regardless of whether you impose the
death penalty or not
because the only other available penalty
is life in person without the
possibility of parole I want to start
with the defense Brian they gave maybe a
five minute opening very quick what'd
you think of that I wasn't a fan of it
hey stylistically we're different I get
it I'm not going to criticize that but
you go through this I'm a zealous
advocate you talk about the punishment I
mean we're opening statements here why
are you talking about hey he's either
going to die in prison or be getting the
death penalty you might as well just
take a plea there and throw in the towel
then he brings up the cell phone towers
and how it's not accurate that's when he
started to pull me in it's like oh are
you going to say that he's here and the
crime happened there that's great but
then he just walked past that and said
okay that's it it was a cross between a
non-opening opening and there's almost
throwing in the towel with maybe one
issue and I'm just like I don't know
what you're going to do here let's see
what you got you make a good point I I
was a bit taken off by that as well I do
want to talk to you about the
investigation mark because it apparently
only took police about an hour to piece
together that the defendant was the
suspect do you think that strengthens or
weakens the prosecution's case
it could go either way now I've
prosecuted death penalty cases I'm here
to tell you the juries spend much more
time focusing on details like that
because they know it's much more
important than a random felony case some
of those jurors might think that the
police got it in their head that was him
early on and then they weren't able to
change their mind you could see the
defense bringing that up having said
that for many jurors who are accustomed
to watching TV dramas where the suspect
is identified rather quickly perhaps
this will make sense to them
yeah that's a that's a good point I I
mean look we're still at the beginning
stages of this and obviously trials are
kind of flexible and malleable and they
can switch all the way I will tell you
one thing it's just a really sad case
when you think about what happened to
that woman and her son and it'll be
interesting to see what the defense will
Mount up because it looks like some
significant evidence against their
client
and welcome back we're closing out
Today's Show with a wild story from
Chicago a woman and her teenage son were
both charged with murder after the
mother reportedly signaled for her son
to shoot a man now prosecutors are
moving to drop those same charges
investigators say carlisha Hood was
inside Maxwell Street Express a 24-hour
restaurant to get some food while her 14
year old stayed in the car now a man
came into the business and he and Hood
got into an argument Hood reportedly
texted her son signaling to him to bring
a gun into the store the argument
between Hood and the man turned physical
and Hood was allegedly punched in the
head multiple times Hood's son then
fired the gun at the man hitting him in
the back the man ran away but the teen
apparently followed him firing more
shots Hood also apparently wanted her
son to shoot it bystander who was
laughing at the situation but the
shooter and his mother got back into the
car and drove off the 32 year old victim
died from two gunshot wounds to the back
hood and her son turned themselves into
police last week and they both faced
felony murder charges but prosecutors
say emerging evidence has motivated them
to drop the charges while that evidence
isn't entirely clear a viral video
surfaced online over the weekend showing
Hood indeed being punched by the victim
now Mark are you surprised that the
mother and son were charged maybe in the
first place because someone could say
this is defense of others
yeah everybody here was acting stupidly
in some respect this was overcharged to
begin with remember a dismissal of
charges The Prostitute could still bring
other charges there is no underlying
forcible felony that I can see and you
can't charge felony murder in Illinois
without a forcible felony that's
probably the charging mistake there's
probably another charge coming because
shooting people in the back is usually a
bad idea you've got a duty to retreat
and the notion that you tell your son to
shoot someone who's laughing suggests
real problem for this mother the
mother's got more criminal liability
here than the sun I think I I think the
idea of her allegedly saying shoot
somebody else was merely laughing
doesn't help the case at all for her but
I am curious Brian what do you think
caused prosecutors to change their mind
because I would say it seemed like a
kind of a tough case when you're dealing
with a young person 14 years old but I
agree with Mark it seemed the more
responsibility was put on the mother but
what do you think caused prosecutors to
ultimately change their mind yeah more
time on this because during the break
Mark and I were talking and I agree with
Mark he's saying hey they're they're
dismissing the charger but they could
bring it back well for me I I think and
I'm not saying one more right the other
I'm just presenting the two ideas I
think the court of public opinion really
swayed the prosecutors to say hey the
writing on the wall is you're not going
to get a jury to convict now do I think
they wouldn't get the conviction for the
sun I think that's very typical I'll
take that case on a heartbeat 80 20 says
you probably win that case but the
mother that one I'm not quite sure I'm
not quite sure why they would have
dismissed against her when you say she's
basically pointing out to go and murder
murder murder the witness chase after
this guy and kill so I think Mark has
some strong points that they could
refile later but I also think equally
that maybe the writings on the wall that
people in Chicago are not going to go
after someone who's beating up a mother
and a 14 year old son comes to protect
with a gun real quick Brian 10 seconds
that's what you think emerging evidence
was I think that's what it is I don't
think there's anything more than that
all right Brian mark thank you so much
and everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we're going to see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America